A lot of people are getting worried about
Chinese investment in the United States.
In the first half of 2016, the Chinese spent
about $30 billion buying up American assets.
One thing people are worried about is are
they buying our technology?
We could go to war with China.
Are they taking technology that they could
use against us in a war?
Another thing they're worried about is the
rule of law.
Chinese firms obey the Communist Party.
They don't obey the law.
For example in China, they pollute like crazy
because they can.
Will they do that here?
The answer is these are legitimate worries.
But right now things look pretty good for
selling our assets to China.
For one thing, $30 billion sounds like a lot,
but the total value of American assets is
about $90 trillion.
In terms of technology, we have a government
body called the "Committee on Foreign Investment
in the United States" whose job it is to make
sure we don't sell advanced technology to
countries that we might go to war with.
The last one, the rule of law is harder.
To this point, Chinese firms have obeyed American
law.
We haven't had big problems.
You would have heard about them if we did,
but we do have to watch Chinese firms.
They aren't used to obeying high-quality regulations.
And we have to make sure that they know that
in the U.S. it's different than being in China.